could you describe the difference
between top down and bottom up
approaches to theoretical physics that
you talked about in the book so you
could try to jump in and say I have a
theory that I think is so perfect um
that I can predict everything from it or
at least predict some salian features
from it that's stop down that would be
top down bottom up is more like you know
like the questions we just asked why
your mass is what they are we measure
things we want to put them together and
usually a good approach is to combine
the two if you ask a very specific
question but combine it with the methods
of knowing that there could be a
fundamental Theory underlying it
sometimes you make progress I mean some
you know the community tends to get
segmented or fragmented into people who
do one or the other but there are
definitely times I mean some of my best
collaborations have with with people who
were more top down than I am so that we
come up with interesting ideas that we
wouldn't have thought of if either one
of us was working individually would you
say the truly big leaps happen top down
like Einstein Einstein was not a top-
down person in the beginning he was um
special relativity was very much him
thinking about you know they were
thought experiments but he was very much
you know the original theory about
relativity is something like on the
nature of
electromagnetism he was trying to
understand how Maxwell's laws could make
sense when they were you know seem to
have different symmetries than we had
thought they were so he was very much a
bottomup person and in fact he resisted
top down for a long time then when he
tried to do the theory of general
relativity or the general theory of
relativity whichever you want to call it
um incorporating gravity into the system
where you need some feedback then he was
helped by a mathematician who had
developed some differential geometry and
helped him figure out how to write down
that and after that he thought top down
was the way to go but he actually didn't
make that much progress um but certainly
so I think it's you know naive to think
it was just one or the other in fact a
lot of people who made real progress
were rooted in actual
measurements